[Música]
revista de prensa de hoy viernes primero
de julio iniciamos un mes pero acabamos
una semana de información en directo
américa rosa premios de muy buenos días
soleados en bogotá buenos días vamos a
ver si se acaba el invierno nos
calentamos un poquito no vamos a ver
esperamos todos abrimos esta revista de
prensa rosa con un reportaje de la
revista new yorker las últimas horas del
road en una de las mayores clínicas
abortivas de eeuu una crónica que se
vivió en un centro médico de abortos en
texas tras el fallo del tribunal supremo
de eeuu que revocó la sentencia
histórica de roe versus wade rosa
exactamente estefanía taladrid y meredit
code lo que hicieron fue estar presentes
en esta clínica la mayor del estado de
texas donde se podían practicar las
mujeres tenían derecho a someterse a
abortos llamada la houston women's
clínica y lo que cuentan es como la
supervisora les relató que a pesar de
que desde el mes de mayo cuando el medio
político filtró las intenciones de la
corte suprema de estados unidos de
revocar la sentencia de draw versus wave
desde ese momento los trabajadores iban
a la clínica sin saber cuándo iba pues
el último día de actividad en su centro
de trabajo ese viernes el viernes pasado
precisamente ya sabían que iba a caer la
sentencia a la revocación del derecho al
aborto en ese mismo día y que
precisamente por eso estaban intentando
a primera hora de la mañana acelerar
todos los procesos posibles sin embargo
explica la supervisora que tenía la
impresión que la mayoría de mujeres que
se acercaban al mostrador no eran
conscientes de que su derecho al aborto
estaba en peligro y cuenta la
supervisora como finalmente antes ni
siquiera de que llegara el médico a la
clínica cayó la sentencia e
inmediatamente en el estado de texas
dejó de ser legal el acceso al aborto
explica un poco cómo fueron las
reacciones los trabajadores de la
clínica abrazándose llorando las mujeres
incluso algunas suplicando para que les
dieran las pastillas abortivas y
practicarse el aborto en sus casas el
médico cuando llegó relató a los
periodistas que recuerda cuando a
finales de los 60 él estudiaba medicina
y rutinariamente dice intentaba salvar a
mujeres de infecciones y hemorragias por
abortos clandestinos y precisamente
acaba y se una de las protagonistas de
esta crónica es una mujer de origen
cubano que apenas habla inglés y que
relata que no puede permitirse tener un
cuarto hijo ni tampoco puede permitirse
desplazarse pagar un viaje a otro estado
para abortar pero que está segura que va
a encontrar la manera de hacerlo y
explica que una amiga le pasó el
contacto de un hombre mexicano que puede
practicar el aborto en las casas
particulares y que si no le queda más
remedio va a someterse a esta
posibilidad y arriesgará probablemente
en cosa su vida no raúl así es rosa y no
dejamos eeuu pero vamos a hablar de un
tema relacionado con colombia porque el
martes se tuvo lugar esta ceremonia de
presentación del informe final de la
comisión de la verdad que busca pues
precisamente esclarecer todos estos
crímenes cometidos durante las más de
cinco décadas de conflicto armado en
colombia con la premisa hay futuro si
hay verdad es precisamente es una de las
claves del informe miles del rol que
tuvo eeuu en todo este conflicto armado
colombiano no rosa exactamente y hemos
señalado como el new york times y el
washington post precisamente hacen
hincapié en esto en la relación entre
estados unidos y colombia en todas estas
décadas de conflicto vamos a señalar un
par de puntos porque realmente esa muy
extensa no todas estas referencias por
un lado el 'new york times' señala como
documentos desclasificados del archivo
de seguridad nacional que van a ser
públicos en agosto pero a los que el
'new york times' ha tenido acceso de
forma digamos pues anticipada señalan
como eeuu conocía crímenes del ejército
colombiano y a pesar de eso decidió
reforzar sus relaciones particularmente
señala documentos de la cia que muestran
como más allá de ser conocedores de las
operaciones del ejército contra las farc
la cia conocía la complicidad del
ejército con a grupos paramilitares
grandes compañías extractivistas en lo
que es la persecución y la matanza
sistemática de personas de campesinos de
cualquier persona organizada en
organizaciones que se pueden calificar
de izquierdas y por otro lado señala
también la posibilidad del conocimiento
por parte del pentágono de lo que fue el
escándalo de los 'falsos positivos' por
un documento fechado de 2003 y por
dejarme hacer me había previamente raúl
el 'washington post' sin embargo en lo
que se fija es en el tema de la guerra
contra las drogas y señala como la
comisión de la verdad pidió al nuevo
gobierno de colombia al gobierno ya
electo que aparte de que revise el
sistema del ejército y de la policía
revise sobre todo el enfoque fallido
para reprimir el tráfico de cocaína de
cocaína floreciente hacia eeuu no
fallido pues sea crítica a estos
esfuerzos recordemos que colombia
suministra el 90 por ciento de las
drogas que llegan a eeuu y precisamente
la comisión nada critica tanto a estados
unidos como a colombia no sólo por una
política contra las drogas ineficaces
sino también porque ha participado la
guerra contra las drogas y el
narcotráfico
es un factor determinante en la
persistencia del conflicto y la
violencia en colombia
ros ahora sí para finalizar esta revista
de prensa de la semana la silla vacía
donde se encuentran gráficos de algunos
hallazgos de este informe
exactamente y ya sabemos no que no hay
que reducir las conclusiones a cifras
porque detrás de cada cifra hay una
historia y hay miles de historias en
este país sin embargo es importante
también ver la magnitud no de lo que
estamos hablando y en este caso la
comisión de la verdad
tuvo acceso a más de ciento bases de
datos 112 para ser exacto de violaciones
sobre los derechos humanos y en este
caso la silla vacía pone sobre gráficos
algunos de estos hallazgos y de estas
conclusiones y como estamos viendo aquí
detrás solamente para mencionarlo
ustedes lo pueden ver desde su página de
instagram vemos que señalan y dibujan un
poco las proporciones que han implicado
los distintos actores armados en este
conflicto y vemos que de 450 mil 664 o
mil el 45 por ciento estuvieron
cometidos por grupos paramilitares como
veíamos pintados en naranja en verde
claro vemos que el 21 por ciento
estuvieron cometidos por las farc en
verde más oscuro militar los que
estuvieron cometidos por agentes
estatales un 12 por ciento y en rojo los
cometidos por el él en un 4 por ciento y
así pueden ir un poco viendo pues las
distintas proporciones y los distintos
hallazgos de esta comisión rosa gracias
por toda la información esta revista de
prensa ya acabamos semana en directo
américa el lunes con masa de revista de
prensa de nuestro programa vamos a
saludarnos